desafiar las curvas del autódromo es su
pasión la velocidad con la que compite
elizabeth le ha llevado a ganar muchas
carreras en todas el símbolo rosa icono
de la lucha contra el cáncer de mama
sale triunfante aunque sea un poquito yo
odio a alguien que mira esto les tiene
que mover reales tiene que mover aunque
sea una minoría que yo pueda cambiarle
su pensamiento y de estar al pendiente
de su cuerpo y de su vida
favorito la stampa rosa acompaña a
elisabeth desde que es piloto
profesional hace 8 años en
reconocimiento a su hermana que
sobrevivió al cáncer de mama y para
visibilizar la causa
porque tal vez a través de mí muchas
personas van a vivir
van a prevenir y le van a ganar la
batalla al cáncer
otra causa en la que participa elizabeth
es la donación de cabello por tercera
vez se lo cortará para que pueda ser
usado en pelucas para las mujeres que
están recibiendo quimioterapia
porque no están exentos de cáncer de
mama
en honor a todos ellos ya muchas y está
en esta lucha para ello
la pentacampeona nacional está
comprometida por completo no solo a
ganar medallas sino también a continuar
siendo eco de la prevención de una
enfermedad que en el salvador tiene una
incidencia de 40 casos por 100.000
habitantes